welcome to this video playing porn du
jour and I have I think I've lost the
last game against him it seems that some
revenge is in order maybe it's a good
thing that I forgot how I lost it was
probably not a very good experience okay
place a six what to do against a six can
you go see five I might take and play be
five okay let's let's do this should be
should be at least good form for a
decent position before or not I can also
just take two not ideal okay but let's
let it take it and play this position
that's it's very solid yeah it's
probably going to play p5b should be
seven this kind of this kind of setup
okay maybe it's going to go night before
him possible okay put something on the C
file yeah always tricky should have
should i insert a four or not could also
try a bishop be one night if I have
tried to to point something towards the
King side it's probably not very very
effective though
and ok let's let's play it play it
simple the night might be tricky on on
it and see for later so let's exchange
this ok s-97 be 64 but nothing nothing
special really ok um maybe I can get an
A for and under good circumstances 192
yeah it's really about equal it it it
always looks a bit a bit funny at first
this is the setup for black with the
basics b5 bishop on b7 but there really
isn't any of any problem with that ok
it's going to put it on c4 ok let's
let's get get something going in yeah a
fruit d one intermediate moose yeah
that's ok I mean maybe he can play
something tactical be to 92 92 something
strange like that it's probably leading
nowhere ok but ok let's get let's go
here what 92 is really not doing much
good ok so i can now win this pawn but
at the end he would have bishop 25 or 25
even 25 is the more more problematic
move really ok so this means i need to
regroup him
especially the night does not make any
sense only to maybe I can regroup it's a
to go to 2d three
maybe I could have played be sure to be
one with queen bee three this is this
kind of idea maybe lie still he still
has 92 there's the strange tactic ok
quindi 3s are completely ridiculous so I
go back to to this plan my sis knock the
sisters not looking too great i gue 95
the ante will play Bishop c4 it's not
really great
what am I doing here in those games it's
not really good yum looks terrible he
can play be three but yeah I really I
really didn't see any any any good good
move to do I just just not good at all I
queen bee three was especially bad going
right into 97b sixth and stuff so yeah I
probably must do that 95 f for 297 I
don't know maybe I'm just losing on with
F for coming but what should i do but
LLC me I don't know it just it's just
not good ah but maybe after f4 I have
some tricks am maybe have some tricks
with Bishop h7 or something and queen
bee one check suddenly getting getting
some strange attack Bishop cheeks and
the check
time morning arts it's chats lost in
other cases anyway him so let's let's
get this going check ya here i have i
have moves i have e for for example for
and then this okay but I am I was
thinking about the capture mostly or
look here okay take them and see what
happens yeah here i have three pawns I
think how many FF two points okay yeah
then it's still not any good
Jim his King is really secure it's not
much not much to hope for you really
whoopsie want something some way to to
get at the king I don't see how
something with F form a BF 4 takes and
it does not need to take I would still
do it what the heck is he doing up
playing perfect chest now or what you
believe check check check yeah I was
really results entertaining some hope at
the end that maybe he would help me a
bit but okay yeah Bishop three fighters
in fact good okay at least playable it
seems according to the comparator losing
right check this is this is only
temporarily good with the rook out of
play yeah whatever what a bad game what
a bad bad game yeah it starts with queen
bee three which is really bad I mean
this is just bad queen bee three I
should just put the Queen somewhere else
I don't know where night ever Queen f3
or whatever but on the queenside it just
gets into gets into trouble and here it
starts to get really really ugly with
this move it's just uncomfortable I need
to go here to a two to make sure i get
in Queen B 1 and B 3 maybe and step by
step yet gets a very very ugly
yeah it's it's very uncomfortable yeah
yeah I saw I for but I mean which has no
moves I'm just changes in a very very
bad shape this is in fact good I was
thinking beforehand i was thinking i can
maybe get something like like this end
but even this is of course winning from
black the idea is his just winning it
only took him took him to took him some
moves blah mmm what should i do after a
six really maybe exchange on d5 I don't
know c5 is probably not really really
anything great it shouldn't lead to
anything special for me yeah maybe I
need to need to do something else here
now I can always play something like
this but it's always a question if this
isn't quite ok for black at least he
gets his size pieces out and I get a for
him yeah maybe this is better ok thanks
for watching